wow i see your shirt ma'am with the
short bangs and the daisy in the hair
yes i see it
i see everything that you guys do happy
hanukkah by the way
happy happy hanukkah um okay
a quick sidebar we'll do more hanukkah
later of course
um i saw something yesterday that really
spoke to me
and my daughter olive has been
struggling in virtual school
and um when i saw this post i felt like
it came
right when i needed it um take a look at
this photo
kids are not falling behind they are
surviving a pandemic
if any of the people in the wall or
anyone who's kind enough to watch at
home if you're parents
i wanted to share this with you it's as
simple as that it came to me
like an angel messenger right on time
and i just wanted to pay it forward
it has a feeling and it reminded me of
something i
i don't know it didn't remind me i have
nothing to harken back on
this is unprecedented i just needed this
as a parent
so i felt it was my duty to pay it
forward
okay thank you to the woman that wrote
that and the conscious kid
an incredible uh site um that aliza
and i dr lisa pressman and i really love
okay moving on to another story that i
feel you also need to hear today
last month an alabama woman lost um
her dog her dog's name is abby the woman
is named june
and um abby escaped from her yard lucy
you are the worst at that i'm gonna have
to i'm seriously i mean lucy
i get so many phone calls it's she's
just ugh
lucy um and douglas won't leave my side
which
i love um and june spent three weeks
looking for abby with no luck and
then something happened and it surprised
everyone
okay i want her to tell the story though
so joining us is
june and her co-worker danielle hello
hi how are you it is so nice to meet you
i love your movies with us adam sandler
yes what are y'all gonna do another one
you know what adam texted me literally
the other day we just um were cut
luckily received a golden goat from mtv
um about being a dude our best duo i
and and and we talked about we make a
movie every decade
and so he's on um the lookout for our
next project and we're gonna make
this decade for sure hopefully sooner
than later
um okay so i'm thank you i'll share uh
this with him after the show i'll get
the clip
um okay so after three weeks of looking
for abby with no luck
lucy she
i mean oh look at her she's like yeah i
know i'm
bad girl um you go to work
and what happens next
okay i'm a cashier at walmart and i was
on register number
six and it was a very busy day it was a
saturday the saturday after black friday
um abby had been missing for three weeks
and
i hear this commotion behind me and i
turned around and look and i see the
security guard and i see some of the
guys off the floor
up there all chasing this black and
white dog
well at first i was focused on them the
dog ran
about to my register and they had her
surrounded
and that's when i started focusing in on
the dog and i said
no it cannot be
and i did and i looked and
i said her name and she came to me
and i looked at her face and around her
nose is white it looks like she's been
drinking milk
and i've bent over that's when i knew
she was abby
i bent over i grabbed a hold of her i
started to hug her
and i lost it i started to cry i
couldn't talk to anybody
well they went to the floor and got a
leash
around her to take her out well when the
guy came up there with the leash
that's when reality came back to me and
i said
no you can't take her this is my dog
this is abby she's been gone for three
weeks you can't
take her and she found you
i mean i do believe in miracles
one time douglas got off his leash and
he went
all the way across the city to the park
and for three days we did a search party
i had my head lamp on at night
and and then at like 116th
i he came running to me it just dogs are
incredible and
you know you posted this story um
on facebook and it went viral and we're
just so happy for your happy ending
and we wanted to give you a little
something from our show to you
we got abby a custom dog collar um
okay she's like lucy and gets out again
you heard me june and danielle
thank you so much i love this story i'm
so happy for your happy ending
all of our love from lucy douglas and
everyone at the show
to you and abby and danielle of course
thank you so much for joining us thank
you so much for having us this is on the
way and it jingles
yes oh thank you i'll send it to adam
you